the thing that's made America better
than most other the United States better
than mobile I can't even call it a
market because there are lots of
Americas it's the United States better
than a lot of other systems is our
ability to tolerate ideas other than our
own our willingness to be offended for
the greater good of a free and open
society that that tolerance is what has
made us who we are and I hate to see us
retreat into a kind of world in which we
surround ourselves with people with whom
we agree who say things that we like to
hear and we only you know preach to the
converted or talk to the you know to the
choir and it's a real exercise in
tolerance to have to hear stuff which
you personally find offensive and you
know whether it's the you know the Nazis
that paraded through Skokie Illinois or
whatever it was worth it it was
absolutely worth it that that and that
the client or was actually the Klan that
that was marching through there I guess
and sensitivity to other people's
feelings is one thing and not trying not
to be rude or
injurious to somebody of some minority
group or whatever it's really important
but it's still a the more important
issue for me is that we maintain this
this it should be fearless about what
you say you should be able to say it
without fear of being I knew how to pay
the price for what you say you have to
take responsibility for what you say you
know but it's really important that you
know that he had the right to do it
clearly and I wonder if we had to pass
laws today they guarantee it's what the
Bill of Rights guarantees us they
wouldn't make us from Congress miranda
laws wouldn't go through Congress in
fact Miranda laws are close to being
removed it's some of the decisions of
preme court now are saying well maybe we
don't really need to read the person
their rights and maybe we can take
things that were said without a without
a lawyer present and we can use it
against them this is all that's kept us
from being like many other countries
that ride roughshod over over its
population and sure an occasional guilty
person is going to fall through the
cracks if you have Miranda rights and if
you go by the rules but do we really
want to be like them nor do we really
wanted to stick to what what makes us
better than them